[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Before
I invite Gina up,
I'd like to tell you a little
bit about her experience.
She has over 20 years
of experience working
with children and families and
is the current parent trainer
for the Early Support
Program for Autism
and for DRTP Research Program.
In the past, she was the
director of the Easterseals Bay
Area Autism Program,
as well as the director
of the Pacific Autism
Center for Education
in Early Intervention.
And she has also
completed trainings
with multiple
developmental-based approaches
and has trained
and supported teams
of developmental therapists,
behavioral interventionists,
and teachers to develop
successful programs
for children on the
autism spectrum.
Join me in welcoming
Gina up to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
GINA BALDI: Thank you.
I'm happy to be here.
Thank you all for attending
and all those remotely.
So I have packets here today.
And I'm just going to
point out a few things.
What I'm currently doing is
the Early Support Program
for Autism.
It's called ESPA.
And I want to point
this out ahead of time
because I certainly will
go through some resources
at the end.
However, you could call ESPA--
it's completely
free-- at any time
and ask questions
and get resources.
And this is a collaboration
between Stanford and Children's
Health Council.
You'll talk to Christina.
It's done in
English and Spanish.
It's 100% free.
There's no boundaries when it
comes to where you're located,
the age of the individual
you're calling about,
or what resources.
We've had infants come
through with parent concerns
up to adults calling for
themselves to get resources.
They may not always get directed
to me for the parent training
piece.
However, we do find resources.
In fact, we had a
parent call from Florida
for resources for
her daughter who
attends Stanford as a sophomore
who is on the autism spectrum.
And so whatever calls
we get, Christina
will seek out information.
And then she'll also tell
you about any research going
on if you're interested
in research programs
at Stanford or
elsewhere and also
if you're interested in
this parent training.
It's a one on one
parent training with me.
It's done over four sessions.
There's no time
constraints to this.
You could do it
remotely or in person.
And again, it's 100% free.
And because it's one on one,
we talk about your child
and techniques to help in any
given situation with your child
and your family as a whole unit.
And then there's other
resources in here
about additional free
classes that CHC offers.
And Christina can even speak
on those if you any questions.
So I'm going to get
into this PowerPoint.
And typically it takes
me more than an hour.
And so if I don't get
through every slide,
don't worry about it because
there is overlap in this.
And I don't typically
stick to the slides anyway.
So this is just a lot of
information about Children's
Health Council.
And you can look at that
at your convenience.
We're going to talk
about a child's success
and looking at it from a
developmental approach.
And we will look,
in particular, at
the interactive
environment-- how
to create a successful
environment for both you
and your child to connect
and stretch their skills
and then creating
opportunities and finding
those teachable moments.
And for parents especially,
it's about finding those moments
throughout the flow of the day.
Where when you have
programs set up,
they'll do more intensive stuff.
But certainly these
techniques are really
important to know and
to hold everyone working
with their child to a
high standard of getting
these opportunities
to teach and teaching.
So when we talk about creating
an interactive environment,
it's really pivotal.
If we want success, we set
a child up for success.
And success does build success.
So the more
opportunities they have
to be successful-- sometimes we
call it the preemptive strike.
We're going to call it
success before it is.
We create that confidence.
And we can keep building on it.
But in setting up the
environment for success, again,
for both you and your child--
and so we look at the yes items.
And those are the
teachable items.
The no items are
conversation stoppers.
They stop an interaction.
And so yes items
are redirection.
It's our items that we can
say yes to and then teach.
We work with parents to
find these in everything.
And so for-- if I'm working
with a child in a room,
the child doesn't know me.
And sometimes will
go to the door.
And you'll see this
later in the slide.
I really want to
be a good audience
to receive all of the
child's communication.
And when they don't
have the language,
I put the language to it.
However, I'm going to put
all my energy and excitement
into my yes item.
So if they try to open the
door, and I said, oh, not time.
flat affect, flat tone--
I say, not time to
open the door yet.
But we can open bubbles.
We can open Play-Doh.
And all my energy
goes to my yes.
And my excitement
I'm not going to spend a lot
of time explaining a no away--
like don't touch that.
No, it's not time to go outside.
We could do that later.
Because what happens is--
even as an adult, when we hear
no, it's a bit of a sting.
And we're listening
a little less, right?
For kids, they almost
grab onto that--
what they were working towards,
that no item-- a little harder.
And that's where
we see the fits.
Or that's where
we see not really
interacting with you so much.
Especially if we're
constantly-- oh, no.
Don't do that.
Oh, no.
Take that out of your mouth.
Don't touch that.
Well, we're not
really interactive.
We're the no person.
So we want to find the
yeses in as much as
possible in these situations.
I do teach no.
But typically it's
in an interaction.
It's in a game.
If I say, is the ball
over on the chair?
And I say, no,
with huge gestures
and a big response,
really obvious gestures
of point and everything else.
And then by a third
time, I always find it.
It's my yes, yes.
So we really want
to find those yeses
and keep away from the nos.
If it is no, flat
affect, flat tone.
We don't want to give a
lot of energy towards a no.
With kids in general, whether
there's a diagnoses or not,
that energy gets a response.
So if it's a exciting no or an
exciting yes, doesn't matter.
So we want the yeses to
be where excitement goes.
Providing interactive
items-- so we
want to look for items
that create back and forth.
Because the teaching comes
through connection and then
those social loops
of interaction.
Teaching in isolated
ways does work.
We don't always
see it generalized
into other environments
or with other people.
And so this approach that
I'll talk about today,
it's really looking at
everything being taught
through loops of interaction.
Because the ultimate goal
is for this individual
I'm working with to go and share
these tools with their peers--
not with me or not
with other what
we call manageable, predictable,
and their control adults.
That will be in the slide too.
So interactive items--
and I know I'm at Google.
However, we stay away from
tech as much as possible.
I can't be as exciting
as tech, right?
Everything I'll
ask you to be today
is what kids get
from what they're
watching on YouTube or
in video or the songs
and dance and all
that colorful stuff.
Certainly there's things we
can teach to that, especially
if we're watching
as well and doing
some pausing and kind of acting
it out or asking questions.
But it is limited.
We get rid of our competition.
So tech would be my competition.
I want items that I
can bring the fun to.
The object is there
to support the play.
However, the person
is the primary focus.
That object is not fun
without me involved.
So you're looking
for items that don't
have the bells and whistles,
the lights and the noises,
the battery items.
So ideally, really basic toys.
I like items like
what's called--
I call them a pole tube.
And you just pull it long.
And you can spin it.
You can do all kinds of stuff.
So thinking of
items that you can
get a child excited to
look your way more often
and want you to do
it again and again
to promote functional language.
Create an interactive
environment.
Again, be a good
sensory detective.
So typically when
I do this talk,
I do this kind of experimental--
I try to give you some type
of taste of what sensory
may be going on with the child.
And we're always doing a best
guess because we cannot say
what effects a child.
We can observe.
And we can make best guesses.
However, when we're talking
about young kids in general,
we know that their sensory
system is immature.
When we're talking
about a child who is not
hitting all those milestones
the way we expect them to,
we're going to kind
of guess that there
are some interruptions in
their sensory development.
And so being a good
sensory detective
is investigating
the environment.
Setting, again, the
environment up for success
is getting rid of items that
are going to be an issue.
So I work with a
little boy now who will
mouth a lot of soft plastics.
I don't bring soft
plastics into the session.
I'll bring hard plastic toys.
I bring items that I
can create interaction.
But I am not going to spend
time taking things out
of their mouth.
I also will make sure there's
a replacement for items
like that.
So if a child is
mouthing, if we're
being a sensory
detective, I view
that as there's a need there.
And as a responsible
adult, I need
to help that child
meet that need
so they don't have to keep
seeking out items to meet it
themselves.
And so replacement yes
items is really important.
If you work with an
occupational therapist,
many times they'll
use a tube, a chewy.
And some kids do well with that.
Some don't.
Or they get bored after a while.
So they'll do it
for a little bit,
but they'll still
grab the other items.
Having other items that
might provide more input--
a wash cloth, a
dry wash cloth does
that because they can
get it back into areas
that a chewy doesn't get.
And then it's more malleable.
It gets wet, and then you can
move it around a lot more.
It's an acceptable item.
I know parents who have
done handkerchiefs.
So they're always
accessible that way.
So looking for, again, yes
items-- even teething rings.
I mean, when they come
out of the freezer,
sometimes that can give a nice
relief for whatever's going on.
And also trying lots of
different pressure in areas,
which, if you work with a
good occupational therapist,
they work a lot on the
sensory system too.
And they'll put a child on what
they call a sensory diet, which
is deep input--
different type of
movements for development.
You also want to make
changes to the environment.
Again, if a child--
get rid of the no items.
But also if-- and you
have great lights here.
In fact, part of my experiment
I do is shaking the lights,
and off and on, and shaking
a bag, making lots of noise.
And it drives most
parents crazy.
And you can't focus.
And I say, that's a little
taste of what may be going on,
that what you're asking
out of your child,
they're filtering through all
those layers of sensory issues.
So yeah, it takes
time to process.
If they could do it easily,
they would be doing it easily.
And so to acknowledge
that it is hard.
And so we need to set up
that environment to give them
as much success as possible.
So having access to a
trampoline or bean bag
or even cushions
for deep pressure
or being able to jump on
the bed, doing tight--
rolling a child up in a
blanket tightly and back out,
which we call a burrito--
and kids love it.
And we get lots and
lots of language
out of activities like that.
Because number one, they
can't do it themselves.
We have to be a part of it.
And number two, it
relaxes their body
and gives them a
lot of nice input.
And so they do
want more and more.
So I keep stretching
as we continue, and I
get them more engaged and
excited about the activity.
So you want to remove
items that are an issue.
Support sensory regulation.
If you look at
activities online,
you just want to try
different things to really
have a nice array of sensory
movement, sensory input
activities.
And it depends on what the child
either seeks out or avoids.
Again, there's a lot of
good occupational therapists
out there.
And if you're not
working with one,
their websites will give
you a lot of tips as well.
You can also search, which
I've done many times,
to get ideas is brain gym.
And then I'll just look at
the images under brain gym.
And it'll give me ideas of
helping a child move their body
in different ways
so they are what
they call crossing the
midpoint and working
both sides of the brain.
Things that when we
don't do for a while,
and then you try to do
it, you realize it's
not as easy as you thought
like jumping jacks.
And I'll try to do one.
I'm like, oh, I think I forgot
how to do a jumping jack.
Or jumping rope,
skipping, right?
Sounds like no big deal.
If you haven't done it
for a while, try it.
You'll realize your brain's
lost a little of that.
You can get it back.
But it takes practice.
And really paying attention
to the child's ongoing needs.
One of the things you want to be
as a good sensory detective is
just step back and observe.
And observe the finer details
of what your child is doing--
that you may want to
look for ways to support.
Because if we can be
a partner in this,
we can play a role in the
need to open and shut a door.
And all of a sudden, it's our
idea instead of us stopping
them constantly from doing it.
They're going to turn
more and more to you
as a partner instead
of somebody--
the no person in that.
Position yourself
for eye contact.
If you want eye contact,
make it really easy.
Be at his or her
eye level or lower.
And then capture it.
You'll see it later.
Again, I jump around the slides.
But reinforce it.
Everything you want to see
out of that child more often,
reinforce.
Oh, good looking.
And do it with that nice energy.
But if you're
working or you have
a child who doesn't have nice
eye contact and you want it,
set them up for success.
Make it really easy.
Take all the
obstacles out of it,
and then reinforce it
each and every time.
And I know sometimes it's quick.
But, I mean, I will capture it--
if I'm working on it,
I'll get it each time,
even if it's in moving.
And then I get to slow
it down a little bit more
and a little bit more.
Promote reciprocal interaction.
Again, everything we teach
through loops of interaction.
And so you'll see it
later in the slide,
but that pause is
really important.
[GASP] And for that
anticipation of I know I'm
going to get something
back, and I'm
available to receive it back.
And many times, I'll work in
a room with no distractions
and where I don't have to
run after a child a lot
to get eye contact.
And so that way, we
can do a lot more
of the back and forth
reciprocal interaction.
She might look at
space like that.
And make it a space that
a child wants to stay in
because it's so much fun.
Because you bring the fun to it.
Offer visual steps when
necessary and schedules.
So it's more impactful
of a learning opportunity
if we see it, we hear,
and we experience it.
I have a better chance of
taking that skill with me.
So visuals are really
important, whether I
have an actual item, icon,
a picture of an item,
or I do it in gestures-- like
do you want pizza or chicken?
And there's nothing
there, but it
helps with visualization,
which helps
with when kids do get into
chapter books and things
like that.
You have to be-- it's the
same as social comprehension.
You have to be, for
reading comprehension,
able to visualize
the characters,
visualize the environment, and
then start making predictions
of what could happen.
And that's the same
for that social piece.
That's why it's so hard.
There's all those
unwritten rules
of what it means to
socialize and be successful.
And so you want to
make it really obvious.
And schedules sometimes help.
Visual steps help.
One of the things
you are be careful of
is to do too many schedules.
And then you get a
more rigid individual.
Right?
We want flexibility
within those schedules.
So if I have a
schedule planned out,
well, I might have a
special activity in that.
If you drive a child
to school every day
and you have options
to go multiple routes,
you want to take a
left turn next time
instead of a right turn.
When you go on walks, you
want to explore, be curious,
and go different directions.
We can do a lot of
flexible demonstrations
even with our speech.
So if I say, go shut
the door, I can also
say, go close the door.
It means the same thing.
And people say it differently.
And so you want to vary your
language for nice flexibility
as well.
When we're creating
opportunities-- and some
of this I'll go through
in more detail--
you want to be
manageable, predictable,
and a child's control.
The social world-- a lot of
things in an individual's life
are not manageable,
predictable, in their control.
And so it's scary--
and especially if there
are sensory issues.
And so that's where you see a
child run off or bite or hit,
wanting to get out of what's
a very scary situation.
And so as adults,
we can be that.
Within that, we will
expect focus ability.
And we'll challenge a
child in a healthy manner.
And we'll go in
that in more detail.
Be irresistible, right?
Be the fun of the play.
And make it obvious
what it looks like.
Invite your child to
take healthy risk.
That's really
important for them.
It's a little scary.
But if I can be manageable,
predictable, and in control,
and give little
pieces of a risk--
and risk is very different
for different kids.
I had a beanbag
one time in a room
where a child does a lot of
really more academic work
and not the social piece.
And he sat in the beanbag.
And I thought, oh, I'm going
to do a sensory social activity
is what we call it.
And so I went and I
picked the beanbag up.
And I kind of gave pressure,
and I just picked it up.
I said, up, up, up--
just to my knees.
And he was scared.
And so I went, down, down, down.
And I did not let
go because I knew he
would be out of that beanbag.
And I know he'll
enjoy it if he can
see that it is manageable,
predictable, and is controlled.
That it is safe.
So I do it again.
Up, up, up.
[GASP] Down, down, down.
And later in the slide--
always comes up for--
I have a very clear beginning,
middle, and end to my routine.
And I'm going to do it
at least three times--
the rule of three.
If a child needs it
more because I think,
oh, he still needs
a little more.
He looked scared, but
he's starting to relax.
And I'll do it more.
But typically, three
does it for me.
And I'll do it again.
Up, up, up.
[GASP] Ah, down, down, down.
And I put him down again.
And then I let go.
And he stayed in.
And he actually
said, up, up, up.
Right?
So I do it again.
Up, up, up.
But this time, I
go all the way up.
And I go down.
And we did it a few more times.
And he tells me, up,
up, up, for more.
I said, more, because
what I really want now
is for him to
say-- it's got him.
I've captured him
into this activity.
But now up, up, up isn't
really appropriate.
You can tell me more.
That would be more appropriate.
So I say, more.
And I do up, up, up.
And then I add something to it.
I add the spin.
And if I spin a child one way, I
always spin them the other way.
Again, it's more
impactful for a child.
So if a child is running
around a lot or spinning,
get them to rotate--
reverse.
I say, reverse,
go the other way.
So I start teaching those
words by defining them
at the same time
we're doing them.
And they won't need
as much spinning.
Some kids can spin
constantly and not get dizzy.
Spin them one way, and
spin them the other way.
Their bodies are impacted
in a more satisfactory way,
and they won't need as much
spinning and stuff or running
around.
It's hard too.
If a child is running in
a circle and you say stop,
reverse, I mean, they're
in this momentum.
Even a child with
diagnoses, they
have trouble then
going the other way.
And I hold them to it.
Anything I ask of a
child, I hold them to it.
Whether I help them or
not, whether they do
it independently or not
doesn't matter to me.
But I do hold them
to the expectation.
So they know that I'm
always going to hold you
to these expectations.
Those expectations-- if this
is where their skill level is,
I'm doing the next step.
I'm not leaping.
We're not doing
brain surgery now.
I want success, and so
it's that next step.
So this is a very
healthy risk for a child.
And I know he's
going to love it.
And so I keep adding
on to this activity.
And I start teaching no
yes in this activity.
Because if you
give him a choice--
or if I say, do you
want to go down?
He'll say, go down.
He just repeats, right,
the last couple words.
And so I want him
to say yes or no.
So I start teaching yes and no
in this activity-- going up,
doing some spins.
And it was in a playful way
of instead of putting him
on the floor, I'd say, down,
down, down on the counter?
And that was a no.
And so I would have,
again, by three
I was on down on the floor.
Yes, yes.
And then next time, I'd say,
down, down like on the chair?
And I'd wait for
him to answer, no.
After I'd demonstrated
a few times.
And he would start to go, no.
I'm like, no.
And then get to the yes item.
By doing these things, again,
being manageable, predictable,
and in control, we're a really
much more interactive partner
in this.
And be responsive, which
is that thank yous.
And you'll see that
in another slide.
So being manageable-- these
are some nice questions
to ask yourself.
Grabbing things out of a
child's hands is not manageable.
Moving too quickly-- you
want that slow approach.
You want those
pauses and [GASP]..
And sounds-- add sounds
to your activities.
They know it's coming.
Again, with a child
with a diagnoses--
they're not my child,
their other child,
doesn't matter to me.
I always do these
type of techniques.
And you get a more
of a buy in by doing
these type of techniques.
So even if I'm about to
just tickle or something,
you know it's coming.
Because tickling is
one of those things
that there's a little bit
of fun to it, but mostly
it's not a fun activity.
Because you get kids cracking
up, but you keep doing it.
And they've already passed that
enjoyable kind of fine line.
But they're laughing
still, so you keep at it.
And so being really
manageable, predictable,
and their control
for stuff like that.
So you always-- I always show
a child my approach like here
come tickles.
So you know it's coming.
They're cracking up
from the anticipation
because it's much funnier
than the actual tickles.
And I'll say, ah,
tickle, tickle, tickle.
And I'm right back up.
But I'm not too far where my
approach is way over there.
It's not so much fun.
Or if I'm too close,
it's a little scary.
It's really manageable.
And that anticipation
is really important
for social anticipation.
Being able to read
something, anticipate what's
going to happen by
reading the environment,
the body language,
the facial affect,
the movements is so
important for social success.
And we can teach that
early on with those pauses.
[GASP] Ah-uh-ah.
And have that sound to it.
I'll even do [INAUDIBLE].
Ah, ah, ah.
And kids think it's much
funnier than if I just went
in and started tickling.
Plus you get a child
looking more and tracking.
So they're attending instead
of just getting their needs met
and then being gone.
Being really careful
with removing things
from a kid's hand.
If a child's playing
with a car or something,
I'm going to join them
exactly what they're doing.
However, I'm going
to have my own car.
I mean, it won't
personally be mine.
It'll probably be another
one of his or hers.
But still, I don't ever take
the child's item from them,
even if I'm trying
to demonstrate.
I do it by joining them and
then offer something in addition
to what they're already finding
mastery and pleasure from.
Being careful about
standing behind or above.
I mean, none of us like
somebody too close behind us.
It's uncomfortable.
If I am behind a
child and I'm going
to help them with something,
I put my hands out in front
and say, here are my hands.
I'm going to help.
And then I might
help them do hand
over hand or
something like that.
Picking up a child, same thing.
Mine or not, it
doesn't matter to me.
I'll say, I'm going
to pick you up.
And I don't wait
for a yes or no.
I might tell him why.
I'm like, we're going to cross
the big street and pick you up.
And then I pick up.
Or there's a car, so you
have to hold my hand.
And then I take hand.
But I let them know
what's going to happen.
I make myself
available, and then I
have follow through to that.
Being predictable--
again, helping them
anticipate what's coming.
And you do that with the pauses.
Make sure they know
what their role is
and what your role is in that.
So sometimes it's
explicitly saying that.
And as parents, I
think we all do this,
is we put things in a
question instead of a comment.
And I know better to
do that, and I still
seem to throw a
question at the end.
I'll say, time for bed, OK?
And I think, why
am I doing that OK?
I'm not asking.
I'm stating.
And so if you're not
asking, don't put it
in a question form.
When you say, oh, do you want
to play or can I play with you,
I wouldn't ask.
Because you're probably
going to get a no.
Unless you're going to accept
that no and walk away--
or let's try it, you
want to try it this way?
And it's like, no.
Well, then I would join
exactly what they're doing.
And it's, oh, I'm going
to try it like this.
And then you demonstrate
what you're going to try.
But you want to make
it clear what's--
no one can step up
to an expectation
if they don't know what it is.
And so making that
very clear what
is expected with little
language and gestures, right?
Put in.
You don't have to
explain things away.
What you want is
that follow through.
And the more they can
follow nonverbal gestures,
the more they're watching
And the more you're
helping increase
their observation
skills for observing peers.
Learning how to
know what's going
on in that social setting,
which will help them
know how to join and maintain
the social interaction.
And giving that time.
Again, with the sensory
issues that may be going on,
processing time is
really important.
So if I say, oh,
do you want water?
And they don't answer, I'm like,
water, do you want the water?
Do you want a drink of water?
Each time I speak, it's
like starting all over.
So I ask, and then they start
processing the information.
And then I ask
again, it's like, OK.
I start processing again.
Then you ask different ways too.
Sometimes we touch.
Look at me, which is
very overwhelming, right?
Skin is our largest organ
taking in stimulation.
And so then I've got to
process that in addition
to you talking, in addition
to maybe some demand you're
putting on me, in addition to
lights, uncomfortable chairs,
temperature, whatever else
is going on, hearing a fan.
We can all sit here and ignore
many things and tune in.
I wouldn't assume your
child can do that.
And I wouldn't assume
your child knows
what's expected out of them.
I was working with a
little boy the other day,
and he said something
about soccer.
So I'm like, oh, I have an idea.
And so I said-- we
had a ball, and I say,
well, let's play soccer.
You're going to kick the
ball, and I'm the goalie.
And I have to stop it.
And he couldn't
act on any of it.
And so I kind of made it really
obvious of what it looked like.
And so his mom later told me
he has no idea what soccer is
or anything else you just said.
Well, he's the one who brought
it up, so I assumed he knew.
And for all of these--
especially social activities,
even things like tag--
it seems like a
pretty simple game.
But unless you play
with your child,
and you see that he or she knows
all the roles in it-- that you
don't just keep running,
that you actually tag.
And then you run away and
try not to be tagged again.
Who's it, who's not
it, what the rules are.
And they've gotten a
lot more complicated.
Kids aren't just playing tag.
If you're at a
playground, you'll
hear them make up a
lot of thematic play,
pretend play around tag.
They'll say like if you
touch the ground, it's lava.
And you're blah blah.
And it's all these
rules now that
make it really complicated.
So as you're playing games
like this with your child,
you want to start to put kind
of themes around it-- stories
around it.
Make it more
complicated in a way
that's manageable,
predictable, in their control.
And again, being a
good partner, making
it really obvious what their
role is and what your role is.
Making sure they feel in control
doesn't mean they get control.
However, helping
them manage this--
the scariness of it all-- and
giving them a sense of control.
So whatever they're
motivated by,
that's where we start when
we're connecting with a child.
And then we can add more
things to it that maybe are not
where they're motivated or maybe
is not a preferred activity.
I can go in that direction.
So as I work with kids,
it's certainly child-led.
So it's their agenda.
I have my goals.
And I never get rid of my goals.
However, I start at their
skill level, their interests.
And then my steps to the
goal is in that direction.
And it's constantly stretching.
And it's really layered
learning because I'm
getting eye contact.
I'm demonstrating lots of nice
facial expression, nice tone
of voice, whatever
skill I'm working
with-- if it's a concept,
if it's expanding on play.
And I'm getting
loops of interaction.
So it's not just me.
It's not just me meeting needs.
It's back and forth.
Being really-- and that's
the whole sensory detective
is responding to
their body language.
What is the child telling
you, but especially
around that nonverbal language?
So if a child pushes away--
I'm about to tickle and they
turn their body, I'll say,
all done tickle or no tickle.
And as they come back, yes
tickle or more or whatever.
But I'm very responsive
to body language
and what that's telling me.
And I put functional language
to that body language.
The toys, again, not taking
the toys away, not withholding.
You'll see it later.
You don't want to
withhold items.
If a child's saying
buh for banana,
I can work and go in the
direction of the word banana.
But I'm not going to
withhold that banana
until they say banana because
I'm not a good partner here.
I'm not user friendly.
They're going to walk away
way before we get there.
And so being responsive is being
that user friendly partner.
Not to stop or interrupt play.
When play is going on, we just
want to keep expanding on it,
expanding on it.
And again, nos will stop it.
Certain items being
taken away stop it.
Being irresistible--
the big expressions--
you draw attention
in their face.
These are things to be
socially successful.
And with social success,
we see learners.
Because they're observing,
they read the situation,
and then they'll imitate.
They'll learn from
what they're seeing--
things we want them to imitate.
And they start to
learn from their peers
instead of having to
be taught directly.
And so we, again, want to make
it really obvious early on.
[GASP] with the
exaggerated expressions--
letting them see your
face pausing, exaggerating
your movements.
If they're working on
point or whatever else,
make it really obvious
what that looks like.
I mean, again, you
think it's no big deal.
But to learn to isolate this
finger amongst all the rest--
it takes a lot of brain power.
The messages have got to get
through our bodies to isolate
these motor movements.
And sure, we do it all the time.
But if the messages aren't going
through your body to the brain
and then back in a timely
manner, you're not seeing this.
And so you want
to make it really
obvious of what it looks like.
Demonstrate it so that there's
no question of what's expected.
Sound draws him in.
Even with bubbles--
if I say, oh, bubbles.
Ah, pop.
Stuff like that, right?
If all I do is this, a
child's not going to watch.
I want him tracking.
I want him invested
in this activity.
I want them making
sounds, because sound
leads to language.
And what kids-- young
kids especially-- do
is they put sound to play.
And so getting all those
sounds going in different ways,
whether it's jumping on
the bed or running around--
and a lot of times for kids,
if they don't have language
and I put sounds to it,
they're able to initiate play
with me with the sound.
Because they can't say, oh, I
want you to do bubbles for me
again.
They'll just say, ah.
And I'll say, bubbles.
And I give, again, give back
the functional word for it.
But I accept the
language they're
able to give me at that moment.
And make that activity much more
fun with you than without you.
And that means being manageable,
predictable, in their control.
Because when you're not,
it's not fun for them.
You're taking away
from their activity
the way they have to
do it in that moment.
And we join exactly
what they have to do,
and then I can stretch it.
But if I go and just
decide a child who's maybe
spinning wheels,
and I go and say,
oh, that's not how
you play with car.
You take the car and you go ah.
Even if I make it
fun, it won't matter.
This is where he is.
He's mastered this.
It fulfills him in some way.
And I need to respect that.
And so I join in exactly that.
And then I add to this.
And I go fast or slow.
I do some concept.
And I do the rule of three with
a beginning, middle and an end.
I'll say, Gina's wheels
are going to go fast.
Ready, set, go.
Fast, fast, fast, fast, fast.
Make it really obvious.
And I go back to
joining at his pace.
And I go, OK, Gina's wheels
are going fast again.
And I'll do that the same
way at least three times.
And if he keeps looking,
I know he's interested.
And then I want more out of him.
What I really want is imitation.
With the little boy I'm
actually thinking of,
he didn't give me imitation,
so I went back to joining.
He kept looking over,
and I'm still here.
And I would just
keep doing this.
And finally he said, muh.
And he didn't have language.
He had a few approximations.
That's it.
And lots of sensory
issues, low body tone.
And so I'm actually on my
stomach to be lower than him.
And I'm doing exactly
what he's doing.
I say, more.
Fast, fast, fast, fast, fast.
And so I give him
exactly what he wants,
but only when he
gives me something.
I don't keep giving.
And then I go back to this.
And then he looks up, and he
tells me again, more, more.
Fast, fast, fast,
fast, fast, fast.
And after a couple
times like that,
I start to decrease my
party and give more words.
He'll say, more.
And I'll say, you
really like fast.
OK, here's more.
Fast, fast, fast, fast, fast.
And I give him more.
And at some point,
I did prompt him.
And this is only
really within minutes.
This was happening
first time meeting him.
And I say, Johnny, do fast.
And he's doing this.
And it was really at the same
pace, but a preemptive strike.
I say, good fast, fast,
fast, fast, fast, fast.
More fast.
And he started doing fast.
In that same-- it was
a two hour session--
and within that same two
hour session, we ran fast.
We jumped fast.
So we took the concept
of fast and we did it
in multiple activities
for mastery.
And then at some point, we
added slow to activities
where they were appropriate.
You don't want it to be--
I still make it fun.
And so if I do slow for certain
things, it's not so much fun.
So that he could
start discriminating
between these things.
Be responsive-- that's
that thanking him.
Everything you want
to see out of a child,
you want it to be
clear what's expected.
We can put that in our
response, our thank yous.
And varying your
language, again,
make it-- you want to
keep that value to it.
So if I say, oh, thank
you for cleaning up.
Thank you for eating.
Oh, thank you for sharing.
I'm going to be specific
and say exactly what I
want to see more often.
Because if a child gives me
something, I say, thank you,
I can assume he knows.
But I don't want to assume.
What I'm really saying
is do that more often.
Just like the kid who
really didn't do fast,
but I said, good fast, right?
I'm telling him it's
fast before it is.
But what I'm really saying is
faster, faster, more, more,
more.
But I'm building
that confidence.
And I'm showing that
we're a team in this.
And so I can say thank you with
good energy and be specific,
but it loses its
value after a while.
Thank you all the time
is kind of boring.
And you want to keep
that value and that kind
of connection of
doing things like,
oh, there's those pretty eyes.
Get excited about that stuff.
It also brings more energy
as you're doing these.
When you think how long
do I do the eye thing?
Shouldn't he be giving
me eye contact by now?
If he's not, we
keep reinforcing it.
And we keep the party
high when needed.
It's like when a child
first starts walking, right?
We get really excited.
You can do it.
We're kind of that
big cheerleader there.
And now that they
have owned walking,
we don't have to say
anything more about it.
We move on from those things.
But we have to be
that cheerleader
in that development of whatever
skill you're looking at.
And the thing about
eye contact is--
because there's
a lot of kids who
don't have to look to
take the information in.
However, at some
point, they're going
to be missing the
more complicated stuff
because they're not watching.
So we do need eye contact.
We want certainly that
receptive language
that follows that was
very, very important.
But I'd hold them to
the eye contact as well.
Let's see.
So finding teachable moments--
those are just
kind of some ideas.
I'm going to move on for this,
just to get to the next slide.
Model functional language.
Again, be that good audience.
The more you receive
communication,
whether it's verbal
or nonverbal,
especially the non-verbal, to
be able to say back things--
even if a child looks a little
nervous about something--
I know it's a little scary,
but I'm going to help you.
You could do it.
Or hating haircuts, hating
to get their hair washed,
brushing teeth, or whatever--
I know you don't like it.
It's OK.
You can do it.
And you kind of let them know
first, top teeth, bottom teeth,
then all done or something.
I'll do the washing hair.
And I'll say, five cups of
water and then all done.
So I let them know.
I estimate what
it's going to take.
And then I get it through.
And it's not fun for the child.
However, they survive it.
And for some things,
that's what we're doing.
We don't want to tiptoe
around anxiety provoking
activities or scary activities.
We want to help them through it.
We want to be a partner and
say, it's a little scary,
but I'll help you.
We're going to do it together.
And then you give
them some success.
You did it.
And then we move on to the next.
We don't have to spend,
again, a lot of time
explaining why
they had to do it.
We just want to help them
be successful in any given
activity.
And what happens
too is, over time,
it gets easier and easier.
Do less for the child
to create openings.
And, again, especially for
help, if a child needs help
and it's obvious to
me, I am available.
And I'll put my
hands out and say,
I'm right here if you want help.
And I'll punch out whatever
word they should be saying,
but I don't automatically do.
I'm right there.
I'm anticipating them giving
me something or asking me
for help.
But they do have to give to get.
And so for kids who
don't have language,
they might put the
item in my hand.
I'll say, yes, help.
Help.
And I help.
For other kids, they might
give me language to help.
Or for some, I'm
ready, but they want
to work on it a little longer.
And I might give a little
reinforcement for that and say,
you're working really hard.
Again, just
reinforcing the actions
they are demonstrating to
me with functional language,
but keeping it really simple.
No matter how much
language a child has,
I do a lot more gestures
than expansive language.
Pause often.
You've seen me do that.
It allows a child
to give to get.
It also allows them
to read the situation.
Because at some point, you
want to be able to say, Johnny.
And he looks.
And for follow through
of things like that.
That's much more
complicated than me
to say, Johnny, come over here.
Have a seat.
I mean, that's how
I'll first teach it.
But across a room, you want
to be able to go like this.
That's more subtle
social language
that we all have to read.
Demonstrate nice social
emotional language and problem
solving skills.
It's really
important for a child
early on to have social
emotional language.
And so we teach that
by giving it to them.
I know it's a little scary.
They're sad or whatever.
And be that yourself.
You don't always want
to do things perfectly.
Have accidents.
I'll have a little
water in a cup,
and I'll purposely
have it spilled.
Depending on the child
I'm working with, ah!
Oh well, I'll clean it up.
Right?
Accidents happen.
But for some kids, their
social emotional response
is over the top.
And so you want to have a
little bit of a reaction,
but then solve the problem.
You don't always want to
go to solving the problem.
I mean, think about
it in your own life.
If you came home to
your partner and said,
oh, the traffic was so bad.
I can't stand 101.
It's always packed.
And they're like,
why do you take 101?
Every time, I tell you to
go blah instead of 101.
You don't want a--
you don't want solution
to that problem.
You're aggravated, and you
want someone to meet you there
in that aggravation.
And then you can let it go.
But if someone's always
solving your problems,
you're not going to really
talk to them about problems
so much, right?
You just want to be matched.
And then you can come down.
And so even for kids who
do have big responses--
I guess you all have
experiences before--
I'll match them in that.
But then I can bring them down.
If it's frustration, I
know it's so frustrating.
I have an idea, let's try this.
Right?
But if I don't match them
there, then I typically
can't lead them out of there.
So again, depending
on what you work on.
So have your own accidents.
Try something and
make it not work.
Doing household-- fixing
things around your house-- kids
love to try and do
screwdrivers or whatever.
Act like you can't do it
and ask for their help.
And make it really simple.
Or opening a water bottle--
I'll purposely have it loose.
Ugh, can you?
And I'll ask for
them to help me.
And then they're able to--
oh, I love when you help me.
Right?
Well, I already loosened it up.
But still, I make it so that
I can't solve everything.
I can't do everything.
So that they can step in too.
We all need those moments.
Pair gestures with your words.
Visuals, gestures--
they're so important.
And so if you're not
an expressive person,
you want to turn it
on for those moments.
Be a mindful teacher.
You want to think about
what you're teaching
and promote that
especially imitation
through demonstration.
When we look at imitation--
I don't think that's in there.
But we're looking at facial,
vocal, gestural action
with objects.
And you want to think
about how they're doing.
As your child is
developing that language,
is there a nice tone of voice?
Are they owning that language?
Are they able to not
only read come here,
but they too will do, come here?
And you can especially
teach that when
there's a couple of you.
Daddy, come here.
Oh, you have to show him.
Do this.
And you could even
do a little hand.
I'll help you.
And you do come here, Daddy.
And then Daddy responds.
Oh, thanks for showing me.
So again, you thank
them for whatever you
want the skill to improve on.
So if language is already
there and you want the gesture,
reinforce that gesture
by the showing.
Make expectations clear.
Have that beginning, middle
and end to everything
you're teaching.
And stick with it
for a few rounds
until they're able to read it.
For some kids, it's getting
them to buy in, making it fun.
And I have to sell that fun.
And so I keep doing
it that same way.
And that makes it really
clear what it looks like.
And for some other kids,
it's important for them
to observe it multiple times so
they know what their role is.
If I want a child to do
fast, what does it look like?
What does it sound like?
I'm defining that word
even as I say it, right?
Fast, fast, fast, fast.
And probably my speed
isn't really fast.
It may not even
change that much.
But I'm calling it fast.
And the way I'm
saying it is fast.
And so I'm selling
the fast concept.
And so it's really important
to make those expectations.
I know you've seen that
on a few slides already.
But we want them to step up.
And make sure it's clear and
to support the follow through.
So the same little boy,
he would have a bag.
And I would ask him
to-- and heavy work
is really good
for most kids too.
And so I would have him
bring the bag inside.
And he would take the bag, but
he would take a couple of steps
and let it kind of
slip off his arm.
And I'd do a
playful obstruction.
I'd say, wait.
To the door.
But I already made
the expectation
clear to bring it to the door.
So whether it's
groceries or whatever,
where do they have
to carry it to?
To the table, to
the door, whatever.
I have it very clear.
And so I put it back on his arm.
And I actually held his arm
up, and said, I'll help you.
And we go to the door with it.
And I say, good carrying
or good listening.
And then he started
to do it himself
after a couple of times
of me holding it to him.
Because I couldn't-- it wasn't
an activity that I could,
in that short amount of
time, repeat over and over.
He was getting
there, and I just was
having it carried to the door.
So after a few
visits of that, he
knew that I was going
to hold him to it.
And he started doing it himself.
If needed, allow for
sensory input breaks.
So if a kid's doing a
homework or whatever,
and you see them
moving a little more,
again, put language to that.
Oh, I notice you're
moving in your seat
or your work's getting sloppy.
How about we jump three
times and then try again?
But don't let him go watch TV
or do something that they're not
coming back from.
It's that sensory input.
It's that movement.
An article came out
a few years ago now,
and it was research showing that
kids who sit on a bouncy ball
are much more
successful in school--
get higher grades doing
homework on a bouncy ball.
And so having that movement can
really help with focus work.
Be animated.
You've seen that.
And there's your summary.
So sorry if I sped
through that last part,
but it's to get to questions.
Oh, you should just go right--
oh, there are some resources
at the end, by the way.
Including-- all these
resources you can additionally
get through ESPA.
And these Yahoo chat groups
for parents only, they
vet it well as parents only.
You do not have to be on
the Peninsula or Kaiser.
Parents from all over different
insurances are on both.
And they're strong advocate
parents who run those groups.
SPEAKER 1: OK, we do have
some time for questions.
And we'll take audience
questions first.
And we do have a microphone
that we'll pass around
for those questions.
Any audience questions?
OK.
GINA BALDI: I gave
too much information.
SPEAKER 1: I'll go to the Dory.
Thank you.
OK, so the first
question on the Dory
is what would you recommend
as effective methods
for disciplining
children with autism?
GINA BALDI: It depends
on the child, certainly.
You want to teach and
get to those yes items
as much as possible.
And so certainly for some
kids, time out works--
giving a break.
But having them try again
is very, very important.
So if it's a child
who pulls hair--
I used to run a
center based program.
And we had a little
boy who really wanted
to play with these other kids.
And he'd pull the
little girl's hair.
And so teaching gentle hands.
Oh, you can say, hi.
You can pat.
And so we were
right there to teach
what he could do with his hands
to get that interaction that we
knew he wanted.
So what is the purpose
of that behavior and then
looking for the replacements.
What are the yes in those?
Because the no is pulling hair.
Explaining that to a child-- why
they can't pull hair and that
the friend won't want to play
with them and all of this--
for most kids, that's not going
to teach what should I do.
And so teaching the what should
they do-- if you do a time out,
you can say, OK, we're
going to take a break
and then try again.
Give them that opportunity
to try again if it's at home.
But then help them be
successful as they try again.
SPEAKER 1: OK, one
other Dory question.
Are there any resources
that you would recommend
for parents of
older children who
may not have the
skill sets initially
to live on their own--
specifically about job, life
skill training, and resources
as well as possible
options such as group homes
or assisted living for adults?
GINA BALDI: So if you haven't
contacted the Bay Autism
Center in San Francisco
run by Jill Escher--
and she does a lot
of workshops as well.
Jill Escher is putting a lot
of time and effort, resources
into older children,
individuals.
You can also call ESPA.
And ESPA can give you
a lot more resources.
If you want anything
specific, they
can give you contacts and
any information around groups
and all of that.
There's a lot of apps out there
that I know are being used.
Again, if you call
ESPA, she can kind of
go over some of those
for work stuff as well.
SPEAKER 1: Any other audience
questions before we end?
The microphone's coming to you.
AUDIENCE: Do you
have any suggestions
if your child is
extremely food limiting,
as far as their choices--
as far as things to kind
of get them to open up
to new foods and things?
GINA BALDI: So that is
certainly a hard one
because we get so scared of
our kids not eating that we
many times will give over.
I mean, and I know the
specialists out there
that work with food issues
have long wait lists.
But a lot of--
and certainly,
you can call ESPA.
And Christina can give
you some information
and contact you
with other people.
There would be no cost to it.
We recently did a--
for ESPA, I do parent
groups as well.
If you ever want information on
that, they're free to attend.
And you can do
remote and in person.
And one was on food.
And one of the tips that
this specialist gave,
which I thought was
really interesting,
is if your child,
say, is eating bread,
well, you want to add just one
thing that complements bread
that you think will be
acceptable like butter.
You don't want to then say,
OK, here's spinach, right?
Whatever they are
eating, you want
something that actually
goes with that item
to just get a different
taste on their palate--
to just stretch them
with different texture,
different flavor.
That would be acceptable
for them to try.
But if you--
I don't know if my
email is on here.
I can send you the presentation
this individual did.
They had a lot of
nice tips in that too.
I'll give you my
email as we leave.
AUDIENCE: Do you have
any recommendations
for when the kids
start to act silly,
especially when they're not
comfortable with the situation?
They start acting very silly--
very, very silly.
GINA BALDI: Yeah.
And a lot of that is
some underlying anxiety--
we see that as, or even
being overstimulated.
So deep pressure
helps with that.
I would put language to it.
Start to help them discriminate
when that's appropriate
and when it's not.
If it doesn't feel
like a connection,
it probably is
overstimulation, right?
So depending on where you are,
sometimes holding some item
that they can give pressure,
squeeze those balls
or whatever.
We used to put weight--
the ankle weights-- you
open those up and put it
on a child's lap.
And that will ground
them a little bit.
Their feet should always
be touching the ground
to be grounded.
If they're sitting
in a chair, you
don't want their feet dangling.
Because then they'd have no
way of grounding themselves.
And they can kind of start
to get out of control.
If it's somewhere
where you're sitting
and you can put
them on their lap
and give them some deep
pressure, that can help.
Just that even weight
pressure on the shoulders
to relax their body
and ground them.
But you want to hold in kind
of a firm hold and with--
not grab squeeze, because that
can work them up even higher.
But just like squeeze and hold.
I won't break contact.
And I will do the rule of three.
So if I'm giving a hug
or something, right--
for a child-- then I'll say, ah.
And there is my beginning.
Hug.
And I give this nice deep hug.
And then I will let up.
But I don't break contact.
And I'll do it
the rule of three.
Ah, hug.
And I do it again.
And then I'll open up.
And some kids will
push back into me.
I'll say, more hugs.
And it's just to
relax their body
so that then we can
have more focused work.
And I can move on
to something else.
Deep squeezes in the
hand really help.
And, I mean, I give
nice firm squeal.
And again, I'll say, squeeze.
And so that's a time where I
won't be [GASP]---- you know.
When we talk about
bringing the energy,
it's not being obnoxious.
Right?
Because I can do it with no
words like, I have an idea or.
But for a child who's
kind of overstimulated,
then yes, it's kind of
lowering it and giving
that deep pressure.
Kind of a whisper and
kind of like ready?
Let's try squeezes.
And I'm always just trying.
I don't know what's
going to work.
I'm taking best guess.
[GASP] Squeeze.
And then I'm just
relaxing their body.
And then we try again,
whatever situation is.
OK, now let's try to watch
or focus or whatever it is.
And I use the word focus quite
a bit because we want focus
during certain activities.
Yeah.
SPEAKER 1: OK.
Thank you so much, Gina.
Thank you, everyone,
for attending.
[APPLAUSE]